I am going to play for you something
that is amazing videos of Ron DeSantis
talking about foreign policy or trying
to and it's really really funny who
would have guessed that Ron DeSantis
trying to talk about foreign policy
would be so funny
we have uh I I don't even know how or
where to start this Ron DeSantis did an
event yesterday in Staten Island which
is the most conservative of the five New
York City boroughs I've only been once
to be honest other than driving through
but it's not a place I'm super familiar
with but I know on paper it is the most
conservative of the five boroughs he did
an event there and he also appeared on
Fox News during the Fox News appearance
here is Ron DeSantis downplaying the
threat that Russia poses to other
countries typical talking point trumpian
talking point so far following in the
line of trump
um and really putting together
with completely kind of Clueless tone a
very similar foreign policy
idea or framework as that which we have
seen from Maga Governor what does a win
look like for us in Ukraine for Ukraine
well I think it's important to point out
I mean you know the fear of kind of
Russia going into NATO countries and all
that and steamrolling you know that has
not even come close to happening I think
they've shown themselves to be a
third-rate military power I think
they've suffered tremendous tremendous
losses I gotta think that the people in
Russia are probably disapproving of
what's going on I don't think they can
speak up about it for obvious reasons so
I think Russia has been really really
wounded here they're really the ones
that have had it tough you know I don't
think that they are the same threat to
our country even though they're hostile
I don't think they're on the same level
as a China yep China is increasingly
pronouncing that
um so this is this is a typical Playbook
okay this is I'm not going to come out
and say the things that a lot of the
people that would vote for me are
thinking
which is like they actually kind of like
Putin they're enamored with these
authoritarian strongmen uh but he's
gonna just say yeah you know there's not
really that much of a thread and we
don't really have to worry that much and
it's really Russia that's been hurt by
all of this and uh the U.S getting
behind Ukraine is actually like really
bad for the Russian people and so on and
so forth but the funniest part of it is
you know Florida Governor tries to talk
about foreign policy and clearly has no
idea what so whatsoever what's going on
here he was asked during the same
interview about
um the visit to Ukraine is this the same
interview or was this later in the day I
believe it is the same interview
um asked about the visit to Ukraine by
Joe Biden and you won't be shocked to
know that uh he doesn't like it things
first on the president's unannounced
visit is this a good move
well you know Brian I'm reminded of uh
when he was Vice President Obama and
Biden uh opposed providing lethal Aid to
Ukraine during those years and then I'm
also reminded that I don't think any of
this would have happened but for the
weakness that the president showed
during his first year in office
culminating of course right in the
disastrous withdrawal in Afghanistan so
I think while he's over there I think I
and many Americans are thinking to
ourselves okay he's very concerned about
those borders Halfway Around the World
he's not done anything to secure our own
border here at home we've had he's on
message right I mean this is what the
other Republicans said millions and
millions of people pour in tens of
thousands of Americans dead because of
Fentanyl and then of course we just
suffered a national humiliation of
having China fly a spy balloon clear
across the continental United States so
we have a lot of problems accumulating
here in our own country that he is
neglecting this is the language of
someone who's running for president I
don't know how else to say it this is a
message that this is not a Florida
message this is a message you give in
New York
about global issues that you understand
very little about and look at by the way
when you look at that clip and the
previous one and what we know about
DeSantis take a look at the foreign
policy sort of package that DeSantis is
putting together blaming the United
States for the Russian invasion of
Ukraine and Biden's alleged mishandling
of things
um attacking Biden while Biden is in a
war zone right because at the end of the
day that's where Joe Biden went
suggesting he would dial back support
for Ukraine and give Russia a more
breathing room to do what it wants to do
minimizing the threat from Russia of
course saying that he was against the
Afghanistan withdrawal even though Trump
was going to do the exact same
withdrawal and when asked Trump didn't
even articulate that he would have done
anything differently
and of course scaling it up with
aggressive talk about China which may or
may not be warranted based on the facts
but it's just his his favorite thing
we're China this China this China that
um this is a guy who does very much seem
to be setting up a run for president and
one that is going to be horrifying when
it comes to foreign policy by the way a
quick look at his event here in Staten
Island and you can see it is an
extremely diverse crowd of a few dozen
white men I think I see one woman in the
audience but basically an
extraordinarily
diverse crowd of white men who were
eager to see DeSantis speak
um why I don't even know uh it's it's
all extraordinarily strange he will
probably announce pretty soon will be my
guess
email Services by big tech companies
scan every single email you send and
receive emails from your doctor your
spouse that's why you get those creepy
ads a few minutes later and other
companies collect your data every time
you open an email from them it's a huge
mess all of this information gets sold
around they can piece together where
you've been who you know what you like
and it's out there forever that's why I
recommend start mail start mail never
collects data from your emails it blocks
The Trackers embedded in the emails that
you receive start mail lets you encrypt
any email you send even if the recipient
doesn't use encryption keeping your
messages safe from prying eyes start
mail never shows you ads and unlike
other services when you delete an email
it's gone forever and I love this part
you can create unlimited email aliases
so you don't have to give companies your
real email address which can really
really cut down on spam you can
seamlessly migrate your emails and
contacts from Gmail Outlook Yahoo and
others it's really easy start taking
your privacy seriously by signing up for
start mail you'll get 50 off your first
year subscription go to startmail.com
Pacman the link is down below